if you attack somebody today you usually
go after the
motive instead of their substance I
learned a long time ago it's always
appropriate to disagree and but do you
you don't cop to you know President
Obama doing that occasionally
too I have never attacked someone's
motive go back and look I'm talking
about President Obama I mean you know
both sides do this to each other it's
not like the Democrats are without sin
no I I'm I'm I'm not saying there are I
mean Hillary Clinton was out there
calling him basket full of deplorables
which a lot of people think cost her the
election well look I I I'm I'm speaking
for myself what I think has to change
and what has to change is the way we
conduct our our our political rhetoric
I'm
gay I don't know what we did there with
that cold open but I'm Dave Ruben this
is the Reuben report it's January 18th
2024 I am joined joined by a woman who
needs no introduction as my co-host on
today's show that's right it's Miss
Megan Kelly Megan how are you I'm I'm a
little traumatized by that clip what
going on with my hair and why did I look
so fat I don't remember being fat but I
used to be fat I guess you're going in
the right direction sister
cuz rare yeah I don't even know I didn't
even know you're going to show fat me
and I wore my Saucy
top you know it's funny so that was
obviously when you were on on NB NBC
which is what now that's about five
years ago something like that yeah that
would have been five it would have been
2018 I think that his book came out so
2018 and even if you watch that I mean
he's lost a lot considerably mentally
since then and he was a little stumbly
fum on the
waistline Megan Kelly lost weight looks
like a million bucks I think that goes
without saying but Joe bid and even just
seeing him there and he's kind of
stumbly remarkable no it's remarkable
what it's like a different person even
if you run sound bites from two years
ago you see a remarkable difference and
that was 5 years ago and I actually
spent some time with him behind the
scenes his wife was there too um and
they it's like two different people I
just feel like she's still together but
he that might have as well have been 25
years ago Dave because even in person
like off camera he was Snappy he was
with it he was clever he had funny
references that I feel like that
person's gone yeah it really feels like
it's long onone we'll get to more of him
at the end and some of the gunness we've
got videotape of it but first I want to
give Megan Kelly credit on the internet
we did this on your show the other day
but I want it to be on the Ruben report
as well because about two years ago it's
almost two years ago that I was on your
show and it was before DeSantis had even
run for re-election or was running for
president we were getting into the Trump
DeSantis thing and you said that the
Trump people are ride or die they're
never going to break it's going to be
impossible for the santis and I I
watched the clip again we played it on
your show a couple days ago and I watch
it again this morning and I was thinking
what was going on in my head at that
time and I think what I really thought
having just moved to Florida was that
covid was going to play a much larger
role in this election that people it was
so fresh at the time that I thought this
is going to be the thing that is going
to drive people to vote or make
decisions and clearly that just didn't
turn out to be
so after the Iowa I give Megan Kelly
some credit you called it right sister
you deserve the credit thanks Dave I
understand exactly what you are saying
about where you were and and it has been
kind of remarkable how even Republicans
have moved past covid and don't want to
talk about it it's like why wouldn't you
want to talk about it what if we get
another leader in there who does this to
us again I mean you think about Trump
with all du respect to Trump he's one of
those leaders who did that to us yeah he
now says he didn't lock us down but he
did lock us down and not only did he
lock us down for those two weeks but he
was calling up Governors like d santis
urging them to keep the lockdowns going
and chastising them when they didn't all
that's been swept under the rug and not
to mention the stuff with fouchy even
GOP don't want to talk about it I I do
want to talk about it I can see why you
thought the Republicans who were at
least on the better side of that would
want to talk about it but I just feel
like maybe it was too much trauma and
people just wanted to forget about it
and that did not help Ronda santis what
does that tell you about the American
people or what even the results we can
throw the results up real quick of Iowa
everyone knows already Trump got a
little over 50% about 51% he got 20
delegates Des santis came in second 21%
eight delegates Nikki just right behind
him 19% seven delegates I mean what does
that sort of thing like we went through
three years of covid craziness something
that none of us could have ever imagined
a mere four years ago we go through all
that and then it has no bearing on this
initial caucus at least
I don't know it's I I expected more from
the Republican party I knew why the
Democrats would want to move on they did
it to us they advocated the wrong things
they suppressed our speech on their
controversial moves so I can 100% see
why they'd move on but why did the
Republicans allow it to go and I all I
can return to is they it was traumatic
they don't want to discuss it they know
they were right they know they were
right about the lab leak theory about
the masks not working about the V
vaccines being not really vaccines and
having potential health risks and
instead of wanting to sort of bask in
the glory of having been so right on so
many things they're just angry and they
want to move on only this core
constituency of like RFK J supporters
wants to continue talking about it and
the rest of the GOP is like let's not go
there it's done you know we'll never let
it happen again but let's move on
because they just don't want to relive
it is that partly because Trump has such
a strangle hold on the party for Better
or For Worse and in that he did give
fouchy an award on the way out I think 3
weeks before leaving office he was
asking there's a document uh proving
this he was asking Dan santis to shut
down again as you had alluded to warp
speed etc etc like if they were to
really focus on it again and if we were
really to get a reckoning a lot of that
would kind of be aimed at him I don't
think that's why I think that maybe
there's some core Trump supporters who
don't want to talk about it in the same
way they don't want to talk about
anything that Trump has done that you
know is controversial but I don't I get
the same sense for from so-called
regular Republicans the normies you know
the ones who aren't hardcore Maga who
are just sort of like you know walking
along doing their Republican thing but
not thinking about politics all the way
or Trump I think they've they all want
to move on that's my impression even on
the show you can kind of see if you do a
segment on covid are people responding
well to it does it get a lot of numbers
when you cut it as an individual clip no
not at all and I don't have a hardcore
magga audience I have some magga
supporters and some not I just think
that they don't want to talk about it
it's it's too upsetting they're they
were ready to move on from it after the
two weeks never mind after you know
years it was a bad chapter they got
sucked into involuntary measures that
they didn't want to do with respect to
themselves and their children and I
think they'd fight like hell if this
came back around but I think right now
they get it they figured out who the Bad
actors are and they just don't have any
desire to dwell there well they're TR
had anything to do with it or not he did
win the Iowa caucus and we've got a
little bit of his winning speech well I
want to thank everybody this has been
some period of time and most importantly
we want to thank the great people of
Iowa thank you we love you all what a
turnout what a crowd and I really think
this is time now for everybody our
country to come together we want to come
together uh whether it's republican or
democrat or liberal or conservative it
would be so nice if we could come
together and straighten out the world
and straighten out the problems and
straighten out all of the death and
destruction that we're witnessing that's
practically never been like this it's
just so important and I want to make
that a very big part of our message
we're going to come together it's going
to happen soon too going to happen
soon Megan are the Democrats and
Republicans coming together over this
has that been your takeaway uh in the
last 48 hours or so no it's a no but I
do think he's trying I mean that whole
speech to me like the softness about
Melania the loss of her mom recently I
think this is the softer Trump who there
he has this gear he doesn't show it that
often which is like I'm actually a nice
guy if you spent time with me you'd like
me I'm not always this combative
pugilistic man um and I can be somebody
who would bring the country together if
only you would let me if you would stop
just you know excoriating me and suing
me and inditing me you could see a nicer
man and when I'm in in a good mood and
you've done right by me in particular
I'm absolutely Charming right that's
that's Trump and he does want the
Republican party to unite around him and
you know it probably is time
realistically for them to do that um I I
think he's going to get there you know
even in 20156 the party hated him he
rested that nomination out of the grips
of Fox News The Wall Street Journal
mainstream Republicans the Chamber of
Commerce and bent the party to his will
and and even in that election where you
had hardcore never trumpers emerging
over 90% of the Republican Party came
home for him so he's going to do it
again and what I saw with him in Iowa
was he's starting the process like look
it's me I've done it again come on get
on board because the stakes are too high
it's time what do you think the other
two should do uh I have said all along
that obviously I was a disantis guy I
wasn't hiding that and I'm very happy
actually look if he ends up as my
governor in in Florida well he obviously
will remain my governor in Florida
assuming he doesn't win this thing and
if Trump ends up my president like in
some ways that might be the best
situation for the for the country and
certainly for Florida um where do you
think this leaves him right now and like
do you think there's any CH like is this
just absolutely over in your estimation
at this point with all due respect to
Nikki Haley and Ronda santis yes I I
don't think they have any chance it's
over it's trumps he won um even if she
wins New Hampshire and she's not going
to I mean she's got a sliver of a chance
of actually winning um even if she wins
New Hampshire that's one state where you
know Independents and Democrats are
allowed to vote it's not representative
of the Republican party and she's not
going to win in South Carolina Trump's
going to dominate there and then we go
to super Tuesday where he's going to run
the board he's going to be very powerful
on super Tuesday he's actually got he's
done a lot of leg work unlike in 20156
Trump has a team that knows what it's
doing and has run the tables in places
like Nevada in a way that's going to be
very helpful to his electoral chances
um the the New York Times Daily podcast
called The Daily did a deep dive on this
the other week and it was actually very
interesting on all the work Trump's been
doing to set himself up for success in
getting this nomination even if he's
indicted um so like he's to set himself
up for winning against his other GOP
competitors and then to make it almost
impossible for them to take the
delegates away if he is indicted or
convicted between now and the
conventions he's playing it very smart
he's got a very good team around him so
yeah I think it's over and I think it's
I see why DeSantis and are seeing it
through to New Hampshire you could make
the case they owe that to their voters
certainly she owes it to her New
Hampshire voters to see that through but
I'm pretty sure Dan santis will drop out
right after New Hampshire and Nikki
Haley will probably declare a win wait
until she takes a beating in South
Carolina her home state and she's out
too B's gone ASA Hutchinson's finally
gone who knew he was still in yeah and
the party you know by the end of this
month or February will definitely I
think be behind Trump
yeah I basically do agree with you I
think my guess is des santis stays
through South Carolina since he skipped
right over New Hampshire and just went
right there I feel like he knows nothing
Good's going to happen in South in North
uh sorry New Hampshire and then you do
South Carolina and that's that what do
you think desantis's takeaway from all
this should be at the end when he comes
back home I think he's going to say
Trump was just too immovable you know
you know immovable Feast he was an
immovable Beast it was just you know he
you can't you know when you're start to
date the guy who's separated from his
wife and he's really goodlooking and you
think oh I'm really hitting it off with
him and he's separated but like the
ex-wife is amazingly good-look and
Brilliant and dynamic and you're like
yeah but there's a window they separated
you know I'm here I'm I'm cool maybe
he's gonna it's just very hard you know
then you find out the ex-wife is Heidi
Clum but she's got the mind of Marie
cury and it's just not gonna happen you
know like sometimes like you you may be
a great package too but it's hard to
insert yourself into this relationship
that's already established even if it
had a bit of a separation and that's
Trump and the Republican party you know
they the separation wasn't really caused
by trump it was caused by Joe Biden
coming along in an election and they
kind of had to say goodbye before they
were ready and then Ronda santis say
like opportunity I could get in with
those Republican voters maybe they want
to marry me and they were like oh yeah
you're kind of handsome oh my God look
at Heidi Clum that's that's how it went
down it was just it was a very very
massive challenge for him I don't think
any mere mortal could have done it and
certainly not given the relative talents
of each men was it going to happen this
time around he's just you you can't you
can't beat a walking ball of Charisma
with slow and steady wins the race it's
just not meant to be I I think that's
the key part because I'm seeing everyone
say oh he should have done this or he
should have done more podcasts or he
should have blah blah blah and it's like
I don't know that any of it would have
worked because of the point that that
you made to me two years ago there was
going to be this group of people that
would not have moved no matter what it's
kind of funny cuz if you had a time
machine and you just threw Ronda santis
in a Republican primary 30 years ago
it's like the guy actually did run a
pretty Flawless campaign he never got
hit on a debate stage he never made a m
like a major mistake the policies were
all there probably more in line with the
base than even Trump but again there was
this this unbelievable R X Factor and it
just is what it is well and we ire so
much of our politicians post Trump you
know be before Trump I'm old enough to
remember like Scott Walker as the front
runner yeah yeah I really like Scott
Walker I think he's brilliant but he's
not exactly Mr Personality uh you know
when it comes to Charisma that was fine
for the Republican party for a time they
were like yeah we might do that let's
let's try him out you know um they
nominated Mitt Romney he's not a walking
ball of Charisma either uh John McCain
wasn't either you know we could keep
going mhm George W bush wasn't he had he
had charm though he he had some charm
and baseball yeah but it would sneak up
on you but anyway um none of them was in
Trump's field of like commanding a room
and the celebrity factor and the humor
he's a stand-up comedian as you know you
appreciate that Talent none of them had
that so until Trump came around we our
standards were lower on how much we
needed to be entertained you know like
entertain me dance for me that's how we
are now it's like oh Ronda Sanders you
don't make me laugh you're not clever
you're not funny you're just a good
leader when did I I don't want that
you're just functional defending the
Constitution making sure the government
can't inject those with I didn't
sign up for this I paid a $25 cover
charge make me laugh anyway so I
think I think he they were all up
against it with Trump and and it's it
won't be until Trump exit stage left on
his own volition or because he gets
called home up above that there's going
to be room for another person in this
you know race for the White House or
this sort of presidential Politics on
the on the right what what what would
you make of the argument that in essence
this was the best thing that could have
happened to the Democrats or assuming
that you're correct about this and Trump
now runs the table that all right you
have the weakest candidate you the court
cases we know a certain amount of people
hate him people think he's Hitler da d d
like this is what they wanted there are
no new voters there something like that
I guess I don't totally buy it I get it
I see the smart people making the
argument people I really respect and
follow
but uh I've got my doubts because
there's no one stronger than Trump he's
just extremely strong and resilient like
whatever you throw at the man it doesn't
hurt him and that wouldn't necessarily
be true for anybody else it wouldn't be
true for anybody else but everyone else
is like Mortal and Trump is like
something else I don't know what he is I
realize he's mortal but it was just
saying like he's got this incredible
ability to resist everything the Teflon
Dawn and and I don't think anybody else
has that you know other controversies
other scandals stick to everyone else
they're not a walking ball of chaos and
Charisma I guess he's both and it's
worked for him so I can see the argument
that Trump's the only one who can do it
that the media do you think the media
was going to let Ronda santis saunter
into the White House they definitely
were going to be bringing up girls from
the high school at which he taught
saying he me toed me or he looked at me
the wrong way I mean madeup
stuff but they the they play dirty God
they fight very dirty look what they did
to BR Kavanaugh you know this a sweet
guy Supreme Court Justice they wanted
he's a drunk he's a serial rapist seral
rapist yeah I mean come on so they're
going to do this to anybody and I I mean
I can see the argument that Trump's the
only one who's played this game won the
game no matter what you throw at him he
Ste he stays standing and he's just
tough as a mofo so I I don't know if I
if I would say they've nominated the one
most most likely to be defeated I'm not
sure if I believe that by the way for
every reason that you just laid out
there that's why I have no problem
supporting him going forward because I
do believe he's going to be the nominee
I said all along Dan santis is my guy
but if Trump's the nominee obviously I'm
going to support him instead of Joe
Biden it's not even a question and it
was kind of funny because not that you
should pay too much attention to the
comments online but I saw these people
like Ruben's going to come crawling back
to us and be broken and bl and I'm like
I don't know it's it's politics you win
some you lose some like it's going to be
all right going to be okay hopefully
maybe always they're always doing that
honestly like you can't did you see
there you see that guy that Benny
Johnson he's a yeah online commentator
yeah yeah oh when he said one night he
did one nice thing with VC or something
one he he posted something on X saying
I'm with B today we're going to go to
this city and that City and this city
and people were like traitor we are
keeping the receipts we see you and I
was like oh my God he's getting all this
backlash he did that with Dan santis too
like I I remember seeing him do this he
went in a car ride with Dan santis yeah
which was actually really entertaining
he Dan santis gave him all this great
stuff on the trans stuff which I was I
was like that's great stuff anyway he's
like going to follow V who's still in
the race and should be somewhat
acceptable to cor Maga and they were
like f you you traitor to the point at
which the guy apologized and took down
the tweet I know what's happen I love
being in my Lane where I don't have to
sign on to any of these people you know
I love just being over here like here's
what's happening here's the palace
Intrigue my God people are killing each
other
as Jordan Peterson says never apologize
if you don't owe someone an apology I
think I think Benny who I like I think
he he kind of dropped the ball on that
one but actually speaking of the the no
new voters thing uh because that seems
to be an argument too that Trump just
can't bring in new voters there seems to
be an interesting thing happening with
Nikki right now where there's two kind
of schools of thought one is that she
can bring in new voters so here's Kaylee
mckin who used to she was like The
Shining Star of the of the Trump
presidency uh he subsequently has turned
on her but she said said uh Nikki Haley
just congratulated Trump her opponent on
his win interesting she has made clear
that she is not running for second but
still is clearly a strong Contender for
vice president politics is a game of
addition and Nikki adds a different
voting block to Trump's base that seems
very true to me like I know the Bas
doesn't want to hear it but first off
they have work together she was US
ambassador to the UN under Trump she did
a pretty damn good job at it I know the
Bas hates like whatever the neocon stuff
they try to attach to her is um but he
is going to have to figure out some way
to bring in some new people right yes I
mean I wouldn't read too much into Kaye
mcan's tweet with all due respect to
Kaye she was his press secretary and not
his chief of staff she didn't run his
campaign she was was his mouthpiece for
like a year uh and now she's at Fox News
where they're very much behind Haley so
like I wouldn't read too deeply into
that now is it out of the realm of
possibility that he chooses Haley
absolutely not it's not I realized that
Maga doesn't want it they've convinced
themselves that Nikki Haley is is
against all the things that they stand
for in particular the new isolationist
strain within the Republican party she's
the opposite she's more of a neocon
that's why the folks over at commentary
and some at National Review although
they're they're I think a little bit
more Pro totis but in any event that's
why they like her um but Trump has to
win Dave Trump must win he has no choice
for himself and I think he thinks
America needs him to win but he he
personally really must win if he doesn't
want to go to jail it now that it's
going to be Trump and he doesn't have to
rely on another rep Republican to Pardon
him or pull the doj off of him he's
going to have to do it he if he doesn't
win now if he's the Republican nominee
he's going to jail and not just like
going to jail and then having an appeal
he's probably going to jail and is going
to stay in jail for a long time
potentially for the rest of his life so
if that's your
situation I think you might be thinking
mag's going to get over Nikki Haley if I
tell them to get over Niki Haley I mean
I know for a fact that's how Trump
thinks Maga feels the way I tell them to
feel Y and he's probably thinking if if
he wants her they'll get they'll get
past it they're not going to sit at home
and not come out for me and they're not
going to watch me lose to Joe Biden
potentially getting him and or kamla
Harris in the next five years as their
president so I'll take that risk because
I need moderates and need Independence I
don't need somebody to help me with
conservatives like I did eight years ago
he needed Mike Pence you know Trump had
always been a Democrat right that was
one of my debate questions for him how
long have you been a republican back
because it he didn't sound like one he
hadn't been living as one it seemed like
a recent thing he had picked up after
watching Fox News for two years so he
needed Pence now he needs something
different needs to convince moderates
and Democrats he's not The Devil he's
not going to do a sixe abort abortion
ban the things that drive Dems to the
poll polls so it does make some sense I
I could not agree more I I when I see
all these people that are suddenly like
no he'll never do it and or I won't vote
for him if he chooses Nikki it's like
you'll do what Trump kind of tells you
to do actually that's a perfect segue so
Tucker who seems to be in that camp
basically I think he said if I'm not
mistaken he would not vote for Donald
Trump if Trump against campaign against
him even further take a look at this
next week estimates suggest that 40%
maybe more of all primary voters in the
Republican primary will not be
Republicans so who will they be well
they'll be liberals like this one yeah
I'm still undecided on who I'm voting
for I'm a Democrat um but I think um I
think Biden's too old to be an office
and I watched the Republican debate and
I think haly I definitely don't agree
with a lot of her platform but I think
she has lot of aention behind her and I
think she's much more capable than both
Trump and Biden wow you mentioned that
you're a Democrat said Joe Biden's a
little bit too old if it came down to
Nikki Hurley vers Joe Biden which way
would you lean them I think I'm still
undecided on that I definitely agree a
lot more with Biden's platform but I
think Hay's more capable of the job that
poor girl she'll be embarrassed by that
tape at some point but she went on in in
that video to explain that the issues
that she cares most about in the world
are quote climate and transgenderism so
that's where she is politically and if
Nikki Haley wins the primary next week
it will be because of people like the
woman you just saw they are the real
Nikki Haley
voters okay Megan I don't want to make
it about that girl who's just randomly
showing up there and whatever let's just
put her aside for a moment uh but the
the notion that if Trump chose Nikki
that Tucker Carlson would actively
campaign against him I mean that's
pretty
intense I guess I have my doubts about
whether Tucker would really do it I
accept right ex doesn't want her at all
but you know in the end the politics
it's a binary Choice there you know yes
you might have RFK J or you might have
you know Joe Mansion but Tucker's not
going to vote for one of them he's I
think he's going to come home to Trump I
think he's going to do it under protest
I think he's going to look for ways to
limit her influence that kind of thing
and listen he'll have more influence
over Donald Trump than Nikki Haley well
I don't think the influence will go two
ways between Nikki and Joe Biden I mean
sorry Nikki and Donald Trump yeah um I
really think he'll he'll tell her what
to do and she's not gonna influence him
at
all I don't really believe it I think
it's one of those things where it's like
I'm taking my ball and I'm going home
but like the game is so fun and you
really don't want your team to lose so
you will play that's that's my bet
putting aside Tucker and and Trump and
and even Nikki for a second what what do
you make of the ideas of these open
primaries like they have in New
Hampshire I'm personally not a fan like
a primary is for the people who vote for
that party the idea that you would open
it up to everyone it it in it actually
instigates people who are Bad actors to
vote for people that they think are more
def you know more able to be defeated by
the person on their side of the aisle I
agree with everything you just said and
I also think it stinks because the
Democrats are much better at it than the
Republicans are why are the Republicans
so bad at dirty pool like CU they have
jobs they have jobs and families and
things to do during the day the
Democrats they're they're on the meth
and you know I just feel like what the
Republicans spend so much time whining
about the mail in ballots and like you
know what remember that what was that
movie remember that movie Malice with
Alec Baldwin and Nicole Kidman it was
such a good movie oh it was so good it's
a thrill from like
1993 there's a scene where Ann bftt is
like kind of grizzled and she's got the
gray hair she's drink in the double
malted and she goes get in the game get
into the game that's my message for the
Republicans quit your whining and do
better like if the Democrats are going
to do all this stuff with the ballot and
the harvesting and all like stop whining
just beat them at their own game if
you're not going to actively work in
between elections to change the laws
then exploit them in the same way the
Democrats do and I suppose I feel the
same about open primaries you know and
also nominating the most radical
candidate in the primary season uh that
you can so that they'll lose in the
general the way we saw the Dems do to
the Republicans in 2022 when they spent
all that money to nominate the people
who could not win and the Republicans
just go along like anyway they're not
very good at winning elections they're
much better at legislating and ideas
then they are actually winning it's
something to put on the master to-do
list for 2024 well speaking of that
fight and what maybe makes them not so
good this this tension between the
isolationist Wing that seems to be sort
of like the Tucker V side of this thing
versus the more traditional Republican
where do you see the kind of energy
there do you think it's kind of a
healthy fight the funny thing about
Nikki like I get it that I guess she's
funded by these people but as un
Ambassador she was quite good I mean we
we showed strength so we didn't invade
countries that was under Trump so
there's a little bit of play with the
way they talk about it with her I think
she did but I think she was enacting
Trump's policies there you know when you
hear her talk about her worldview
there's no question she's much more she
sounds like a Newan yeah well she's all
in on Ukraine for sure she's all in on
Ukraine and I think she's you know very
much a defender of Israel and I get that
and she's very aggressive about the way
she talks about Iran she just has a
bellicose language to her that is
unnerving I think to a large section of
Republicans who feel burned by the
20-year Wars and have been lied to by
the government especially by Republican
presidents that they believed in and
kind of just have just had it they've
just had it and they don't believe in
these military leaders they believe in
the military guys but not the leaders
and we hear that from a lot a lot of
military rank and file that we all love
and respect so I just think they think
she she's too flippant about the use of
American military power and too tied to
those Industries and we'll be too quick
to say yeah let's send them without
realizing what it's going to do to you
know you've got two little boys now I've
got two boys I got a daughter too I
realize they can go but they can't be
drafted yet women cannot yet drafted
anyway this is what I hear so I don't
know how this fight pans out to tell you
the truth they haven't really had to
have the
fight recently you know Trump was a
little bit more isolationist though
willing to drop a bomb when he needed to
hi solomani um and then we had Biden who
is I wouldn't describe him as a neocon
but he is you know he's not an
isolationist either like he's kind of
trying to thread the needle so now the
Republican party is at a Crossroads you
know Trump is yeah he's more
isolationist but we are facing a much
more dangerous World in large part
thanks to Trump's predecessor so what
does he do now what would Trump do with
these houthis what would he do if you
know Iran amps things up which it very
well might as soon as this week you know
what would Trump do if if Putin did
finish in Ukraine and move on to another
country like a NATO country I don't know
the answers to those questions would the
would the isolationists like Tucker
become more bellicose and support you
know a more neocon type policy if a
president Trump were at the wheel only
time will tell right I suppose if Trump
was for it as we said earlier they
probably would but I do think some of
those countries and actors probably
wouldn't do some of the things they've
been doing because Trump was so
unpredictable right you drop the mother
of all bombs what the hell is this guy
going to do next so you just don't right
like that's kind of the idea I said that
I have said that and I and I see that
that's that is how I see his four years
he already served but I don't know that
that's what's going to happen in the
four years he might yet serve you know
the world is a very different place
right now it just it's exploded Joe
Biden's weakness has invited a lot of
provocative actions and um the United
States is not as strong as it was it's
not perceived as the threat at once was
mhm and they understand now the mood of
the American people and of Trump's base
is is to not get involved you know it's
it feels very like the way I'm told it
was here in America after World War I
and the buildup to World War II they
were done they didn't want it they were
like we just fought a war we don't want
to we don't want to get involved you
know it took a lot to drag us into World
War II um so I I do think we're headed
for some bigger foreign policy
challenges going into to the next term
no matter who's President uh and I think
even president Trump might wind up
disappointing the more isolationist wing
of his party because the world's just so
on fire he's going to be forced to make
some very difficult decisions so I I've
been saying on my show for quite some
time now but I think it's really ramped
up since October 7th that the one group
of people that it seems to me really
could switch parties right now are the
disaffected libs the kind of old me and
I think I think you to some extent um I
would never live unless I was in my like
20s we we'll count that we'll count that
a little bit but for you as for you as I
would consider you sort of as moderate
as possible like logical and moderate as
possible for someone that can be in
politics um but that leads you to
generally I think but correct me if I'm
wrong more so supporting people that are
on the right now what would you as a New
Yorker who you know you've lived in New
York for many years New York media girl
all of that stuff say to your friends
that are that are left leaning but
waking up to the craziness of the Dems
but that that are still afraid to ever
actually pull the lever for Republicans
that that means that they're somehow
evil and they hate poor people and
they're kind of racist and all of that
crazy nonsense I'm sure you have some of
those people in your life like what
what's the messaging that Republicans
should be doing on
that well what's the messages messaging
Republicans should be doing versus what
my own messaging is is different so I
was liberal when I was very young like
in my 20s you know like your typical I
wasn't really political but if I had to
like check a box I would say I was more
liberal than conservative and my my
social approach I think was more liberal
you know even into my 30s uh but
fiscally and militarily and in some
other ways I was more I was more right
leaning um now I took a test like a year
or two years ago one of those online
tests about your positions and it said
I'm I'm a Conservative Republican I'm
like a very conservative Republican I'm
like oh I I am now I didn't realize but
okay you know the the world has shifted
underneath my own feet yeah and what
used to be normal policies are now
considered very conservative Republicans
so that's fine I I'm not a republican
I'm an independent people call me a Rino
I'm like oh it's worse than that it's
not I'm not even right I'm not even
saying it yeah no it's far worse than
you know um but I am more conservative
so whatever that is I don't try to
convince anybody when it comes to
politics I just feel like Life's Too
Short you do you one of my best friends
in this world in 2020 was out there
literally campaigning for Joe bid
like trying to get people to go to the
polls for Joe Biden we would sit we we
talk about it a little I'd never tried
to convince her not to do it I didn't
think it was fruitful and when he won we
all had dinner together and I remember
saying I'm happy you got what you work
so hard for that's it was I happy Joe
Biden won no I was not but I'm not in
the business of trying to get voters to
change their hearts and Minds I just
think good sense will eventually do it
so this same woman to take for her for
an example kids in New York City School
Co hit they shut her schools down for
over a year she has the money to send
her kids to private school she was in
public school because she felt like I
grew up in this town and I owe it to my
town you know I owe it to sort of life
she was a lefty you know like Public
Schools is the way to go like I
shouldn't pull them out and put them in
some privilege environment well as a
result what did she get she got her kids
out of school for a year finally went to
an open the schools rally you know what
happened she was called a white
supremacist by a bunch of protesters who
were standing there that's when I saw
the light bulb go on right like wait a
minute what's happening maybe I've made
some bad decisions and then it started a
spiral from there you know like the
getting shamed all the time in the lobby
of her building for not wearing a mask
her kids not being able to play
basketball unless they were double vaxed
at age 13 you know and and so on and so
forth so I really and by the way she
happens to be Jewish so now I mean she's
in full Maga gear she's a registered
Republican she ran for City Council as a
republican she's more right than I am so
like life had a way of transforming her
and I was just kind of over there going
come on in the water's fine it's fine
but for people who are not ready to pull
the lever for Republican because of
branding I think we have to seed that
the Republican branding is terrible you
shouldn't want to share a jersey with
them they're ridiculous they have absurd
people like why would you want to um You
Don't Have To You Don't Have To Go full
Republican you know you can you can be I
am you can be a registered independent
you can just vote like a like a sane
person and be free to call out the
nonsense on both sides so that's kind of
what I would say if I were a registered
Republican maybe I would say it a little
differently but I'd say you don't have
to adopt all of us or all we stand for
you just have to understand what pulling
that lever for the Dems will get you you
know little boys penises are going to be
chopped off 13-year-old girls are going
to have their breasts chopped off we're
going to have millions more illegal
immigrants coming into this country with
yeah diseases with fentanyl that's going
to kill American kids um with a desire
to vote Democrats so they can get more
entitlement spending which you and your
children are going to have to spend pay
for environmental policies that want to
take away your gas stove and your gas
fireplace while the people pushing them
are driving huge SUVs and flying private
while they're Jets wait for them to load
up their ski gear I mean like it's it
doesn't if you're paying any attention
at all it doesn't take long to see the
nonsense unless you've already been
totally indoctrinated on the farle yeah
that's why I say all the time I'm very
proud to be to be a Florida Republican
which is the first time that I ever
registered Republican but saying that is
very different than saying I'm a
national Republican or something like
that I don't know what that means but I
do know what it means in the context of
Florida very clearly like we we really
do do it right here but let's uh
transition from doing it let's
transition from doing it right to doing
it wrong uh we talked a little bit about
Joe Biden up top uh but they're still
pushing him out there and just this is
from last Friday look at this guy on the
campaign Trail and and just please
explain to me how anyone is watching
this and thinking that he should be the
president of the United States this is
uhg
Sherin this is Morgan Sherwin and uh Sam
Udi there are our team members here they
help us they uh they help us uh you know
service and
sales confid in Secretary Austin I do
I'm sorry how you doing was it the in
judgment for not to tell you earlier
yes all right Megan I'm not even sure
what's going on with the little girl in
the whispering we've seen a lot of those
videos so let's we can put that one
aside if you want but the other one the
stiffness in the hands the stiffness in
the gate the that look in his eye as if
he has no idea where he is the the
random guy stopping him like touching
the president don't walk over
there what I how is this real life I
know it's dark I mean it's really bad
it's really getting to the point where
you want to ask yourself like why
doesn't Jill step in like why why we
know why Hunter doesn't step in but like
why doesn't family step in to say you're
you're done you know you don't have to
exit this way you were in the senate for
50 years like had a good career
Democrats love you you became vice
president and president it's time it's
time to pass the Baton there are other
Democrats who can do this I mean look at
Dean Phillips I had that guy in my show
the the congressman from Minnesota he's
a CEST guy he's not his politics are not
for me but I like him he could do it
he's young he's vibrant he he was used
to run Talent ice cream you know that
was his oh is that right yeah tent is
pretty good and he plays hockey I saw a
video of him playing hockey my he's
vibrant he's smart he's better than Pete
Buddha judge but anyway my point is they
do have other options RFK J I realize
they don't like like him but he's
another brilliant option uh Joe Mansion
he's another option who's more Centrist
who could win um even within the
Democrat hard left field like Gavin
Newsome is at least vibrant people think
Joe Biden's a moderate he's not he's as
left as Gavin Nome or at least he's
allowing the people around him to be
right so at least we get somebody with
good hair I don't like whatever there's
opportunity to sub this guy out so why
why why they think he's got some magic
Talent of beating Donald Trump because
the last time um good luck with that
plan I the the him like wandering around
as you know it's not a one-off we get we
get those once a day and there was some
democrat being asked about it on TV the
other day and his defense of it was you
know 81 it's not that old you know my
mom is 88 and she's still driving it's
like yeah okay that's not the dunk you
think it is like you know right that's
like she's not leader of the Free World
she doesn't have the power with her mere
words to start a World War she doesn't
have access to the nuclear codes and at
a time when you know aopo of our earlier
conversation America feels kind of weak
and weekend these days he's almost just
the the perfect avatar for that weakness
so it kind of disturbs me on a few
levels we need there is something about
Trump and I've said publicly and he got
mad at me he's lost a few steps he has
um I know he doesn't like hearing it but
he's lost a few steps from 16 but
there's no comparison between these two
men and the thing about Trump that is
attractive in comparison to Biden in
this vein is remember Trump at the G7
when he went up to the guy from
Montenegro and he grabbed him on the
shoulder get out of here yeah right like
bolded you know right past him yeah
we'll we'll throw to some b-roll of that
as we're doing this it's brilliant I I
loved that it's like we're the United
effing States of America move back
Montenegro get out of the way like I
liked it I have to say I think a lot of
people liked it they like a strong man
they like feeling like yeah USA you know
backtack World Championships and like
it's when you look at Joe Biden you feel
all the opposite you feel like you've
got the losing team in a football season
that's never going to be able to get the
ball across the end zone that is kind of
an embarrassment there's no that the
seats in the stadium are empty and you
just kind of feel bad cuz it's been so
long since you've had a winning season
th that psychology is at play when you
look at both men and I do think the
Democrats are in a lot of trouble if
they're just banking on oh he's Centrist
Joe he's like the sweet Joe from
Scranton we bought that lie once I think
the American public have realized it's
not true he's not this sweet Centrist
guy and he's incapable of staying on
this job for four more years right and I
don't I actually don't know which one is
worse whether he's as incapacitated as
we all think I mean no one in their
right Minds thinks he could work one
shift at McDonald's and I don't mean
that as a shot to anyone that works at
McDonald's I don't think he could work
one shot behind the one daily shift
behind the counter at McDonald's that's
one thing but I don't know what's worse
that or if there's a shadow government
basically behind him pulling the strings
like is that Barack Obama or who which
one of those things would even be worse
who knows who did we elect I don't know
but right this is one of the things you
know I think a lot of people who aren't
paying attention don't really even
realize how deep the Dei stain has gone
into our government into our schools
thanks to his leadership and his plan
the same with the transgender ideology
he is not Centrist he's radical I mean
or the people around him are I don't
really give a damn at this point because
it's the same you know in terms of its
effect and so you know you I was talking
to that guy Dean Phillips who made Dei
part of his platform as this Democratic
Challenger and then I start asking him
about some of these radical plans I
don't think he even knew some of what
Joe Biden was doing that those letters
do not stand for what many people think
they Doh uh either way for me it's like
the bottom line anybody who believes in
any of that nonsense has got to go I
could never vote for somebody who's
behind dividing Us by race allowing
little children to chop off body parts
before they've reached the age of
majority before they can smoke a
cigarette and Joe Biden's 100% in favor
of all that nonsense feeble or not what
it might all boil down to of course is
that the lady behind him is not that
impressive here is Cala Harris earlier
this week look what happened in
Georgia passed a law to make it illegal
to give people food and water who are
standing in line sometimes for hours to
vote what happened to Love Thy
Neighbor the hypocrisy
abounds I see our college
students and let me just tell you I love
jenzy I don't know something you know I
love jenzy we love you we love you so
okay for the older ad all this is going
to be a humbling thing I'm about to
share with you if someone is 18 years
old today they were born in
2005 oh yeah check that out think about
that for a
[Laughter]
minute look who's walking around with an
abacus um idiot Megan does that answer
your your previous question which is
like well why can't they get rid of him
that's kind of why because they know
that like okay if you could bring in
Dean Phillips or if you could bring in
RFK or anyone else magically well you
still have to get rid of her and that's
what they're up against right now
because nobody's going to vote for
her aren't you feeling sorry for
yourself right I'm feeling sorry for me
you why am I feeling sorry for Megan
Kelly how do we get stuck with these two
how do we getu existentially yes I feel
bad for all of us yeah did you to go on
with her like in that same speech with
her like what we needs to be unburdened
by what has been which she says like
every other day as though it's a
newfound profundity that she's come up
with and she absolutely loves has almost
as much as her ven diagram she loves ven
diagrams sandwich she's also Russia's
big Russia's big Ukraine's small
remember that one that was a good one
it's a country and it's right next to
Russia and it's yeah yeah so yes she is
a massive problem for him though I do
think there's a way of getting rid of
both of them I really do I just think
like Joe Biden can say you know it's
time to pass the Baton and the new
person is going to need to choose his
own vice president like sort of approach
it as though obviously you know I'm
seeding to the next runner for president
and that person's they're going to have
to compete you know Michelle Obama and
Gavin Newsome and P judge and kamla
Harris are going to have to compete for
it right yeah like make it a contest but
the Democrats will never put her in but
he cannot pass the Baton to her because
they will lose and they know that so I
do think there's a way there's a way of
getting rid of both of them but he won't
seed he is not he is not going to seed I
don't believe he's going to seed power I
don't remember in recent history any
president ever doing that you know when
when they thought that they had a chance
of actually being reelected so they're
stuck with them and the problem with her
presence this is what happens you know
live by identity politics die by
identity politics he chose her he said
because she's a black woman same as
katangi brown Jackson same as what
they're now saying at Harvard has to be
another black woman it does why anyway
now he can't get rid of her because
who's the most loyal group of democrat
voters right it's black women right he's
losing black men to Trump already like
by the droves he's losing Hispanics but
he's not losing black women and already
some black women who are prominent
social commentators have said don't you
dare and also don't sub bid Michelle
Obama Obama because quote we're not
interchangeable that's a quote from
Sunny htin of the view she's weighed in
on she's not the only one several she'd
be interchangeable with the traffic con
you can't get rid of Kamala like it's a
hard no so they've tied their hands and
unfortunately if he wins again they've
tied all of our
hands Megan come uh mid January
2025 who will be president of the United
States and then I will let you
go
I hate when people ask this because I
don't I know and that's why I'm doing it
because you got me on that other one
with the Trump and the santis thing and
now we'll just have a clip out there
hanging
there um I'm gonna have to say Donald
Trump I just think I know I know we're
about to go through a year of indict not
indictments criminal trials and probably
convictions and maybe even the Rogue
judge who sends him into jail pending
appeal unlikely but maybe
Trump grows with every controversy and I
think it will be true this year as well
I've never seen the Republican base so
angry about something even the ones who
don't like him are going to try to send
a message that that kind of
electioneering that the Dems are doing
to him is not okay and Joe Biden over
the next year is likely to have a fall
or an impossible to ignore a senior
moment and so I'd have to say Trump
Megan as I always tell you you're on the
top of my very short list of people who
make me think that there are sane people
in the world and we might exist in a
couple years from now uh I feel like I
owe you a bottle of tequila because of
that Trump Dan santis thing for do you
have a specific type or do I have carp
lunch here yeah car lanch as long as
it's like you know white tequila I don't
want like any of the yellow stuff like
this low brow something something
elevated please you want a chrystalino
I'll take it send it my way I've learned
if you put an orange slice in it like an
orang orange rind not the slice it
changes the whole thing you can have it
over rocks without the caloric mixers
boom you're home as they say when
they're drinking tequila arios
Amiga I just want to tell you that
America is the greatest place on
[Music]
Earth
I
[Music]
dream